et pour daniel dalin secrétaire général
conseil représentatif des français
d'outre-mer il va falloir du temps pour
régler des problèmes ancrée depuis des
années que
ça m'étonnerait qu'on rend en une séance
en une séquence monsieur le corps nu
avec toute l'équipe malgré toutes ses
qualités puisse régler régler le
problème le problème il est beaucoup
plus profond que ça et l'essentiel c'est
que là le contact a été très peu repris
entre autres comment dirais-je entre les
deux entre les deux parties mais je
pense que si c'est autour d'une table
ronde autour d'eux 2 on va dire un plan
marshall totalement poreux pour les
outre mer qu on pourra dire que les
doléances ont été en partie réglé parce
que ça m'étonnerait qu'au bout de dix
minutes qu'on puisse de régler des
choses ils sont testés depuis des années
des années il faut il faut que le
ministre entendre que ce n'est pas
uniquement le pack vaccinale et
d'obligations le pass anita une
obligation vaccinale qui nient qu'ils
italie pas uniquement de ça il s'agit de
toute une série de problématiques qui
ont plongé nos départements d'outre-mer
guadeloupe martinique guyane réunion
dans la contestation et qu'au delà de ce
pack sanitaires il faudra apporter des
réponses